yahoo le portail internet américain a
fait appel devant un tribunal
californien d'une décision de la justice
française visant à empêcher le public
d'accéder à une vente aux enchères
d'objets nazis
la loi française est claire elle
interdit toute image à caractère nazi au
pédophile mais les fournisseurs d'accès
à internet sont de plus en plus
préoccupée par les fraudes
et justement une start up française
vient d'inventer un filtre anti images
pornographiques
un logiciel qui pourrait même débusquer
tous les sites illégaux
le reportage de dominique vadel et
myriam métaoui la surprise est pour le
moins inattendu lorsqu au beau milieu
d'un site touristique à noda apparaît
soudain des photos pornos indésirables
aussitôt et c'est ça la nouveauté une
croix s'afficher donne l'alertent chez
l'hébergeur de sites où le site à
délicat peut alors être immédiatement
supprimé cette chasse automatique aux
images illicite est possible grâce à un
logiciel
c'est un film qui analysent
systématiquement les images mais il a
aussi en mémoire des mots qui le fait là
aussi immédiatement réagir pour le texte
exactement comme il ya des types d'image
que vous voulez pas voir pour le texte
où il ya des types de maux que vous ne
voulez pas revoir ou en tout cas vous
mettre la puce à l'oreille sur le
contenu ou les images publiées sur ce
site
grâce à cette analyse de texte le
logiciel peut donc débusquer les offres
nazis pédophiles ou encore
révisionnistes et au total c'est un
marché prometteur puisque des politiques
européens veulent affiner les lois sur
le net face à des petits malins qui
créent des sites interdits mais passent
entre les mailles ce sont les hébergeurs
simples intermédiaires techniques qui
deviendrait aussi responsable du contenu
des contenus qui pourtant ne font que
passer dans leurs tuyaux mais qu'il
devrait contrôler et pour bon nombre de
juristes cette nouvelle
responsabilisation sera lourde de
conséquences
on est responsable de ce qu'on fait de
ce qu'on publie mes l'intermédiaire
technique
ça n'est pas un exercice facile que
penser qu'ils pourraient être
responsables
oki des cons
on a recherché systématiquement le plus
solvable et puis celui qui était de cali
sable et qui était présent et qu'on
pouvait presque toucher avancement
dématérialisé donc c'est vrai que les
plus riches les plus forts on s'en
accommoder bien facilement que les
autres
nous sommes chez nyx den une start up
montées en juillet dernier âge moyen des
fondateurs 25 ans est une des
spécialités l'hébergement de sites on
les contrôle déjà mais devenir
juridiquement responsables pour une
petite entreprise
ce n'est pas simple nous avons
actuellement plus de dix mille sites qui
sont en fonctionnement qui sont plus
basées sur les technologies de mini qui
permettent sans même l'intervention de
l'auteur de rechange et entièrement son
contenu pourront pas techniquement
intervenir tous les jours pour vérifier
dix mille sites et c'est donc justement
pour ça disent ses auteurs que la
technologie des filtres risque de
devenir indispensable de puidoux